all right welcome to beyond the basics
I'm filming filling in for Ben Feingold
tonight he's at cortex doing a symbol so
he'll be back for the the class at 7:30
but but this time I'll be be filling in
and this is beyond the basics which is a
beginner course of sort of meant for you
know how the pieces move at least in
theory but in practice like FM's come to
this class and really strong players
come so it's really sort of a mix and
we're going to throw it on the internet
and there'll be a whole mix of rating
ranges and whatever so today I thought
we'd go over some really quick games
some games that ended quickly miniatures
and I had something prepared and then it
was on a different computer and now
everything's lost so my backup plan
which is actually my backup backup plan
is to go over this list that I was given
it's 50 great games so I guess I'll let
the audience just pick a number and
we'll go over a great game we'll see how
great they are see if see if that's
really true so with that in mind does
anyone have a number between 1 and 50 42
all right hope it's a good one all right
so this will be the first game yeah it's
42 all right so I'll go over this this
game is a quick one this is varnish
Jenin from 1948 so I think most of these
are efore openings but this one is a d4
so we got d4 d5 and now II for hmm so we
got is it going to be a black mark
Deemer so in this position Knight c3 f3
also is another way to continue in
gambit experi that will happen in just a
second and so that does happen so we get
the black more Deemer
and after this takes there are actually
two ways to take back night takes is the
more popular but in this game the Queen
took on f3 and and black just decided to
take the pawn which you're not supposed
to be able to do so we'll see why okay
so the first move here they attack the
Queen the Queen went to be for I guess
what would you guys play in this
situation so your your be pawn is
attacked Castle queenside excellent that
was what was played and alright now the
bishop went to g4 and I believe this is
called the hollis our trap there's a
trap associated with this so here white
actually has a really strong move at
night b5 which threatens mate so
obviously if you take when you get
checkmated so the rook is doing a great
job so let's see what happened in this
game the move played was e5 um okay that
it's legal all right how would you guys
continue here with white because I think
another way that Queen takes here yes
okay very interesting so you're
attacking the rook it's good enough does
it does appear good enough
how will I defend maybe I can go here
but then Knights e7 yeah so whatever is
wherever you move your knight
unless you move your night with check oh
yeah this is yeah that's a pretty strong
move okay yeah so we're noticing there's
some some issues here in the game he
chose to go in for this check
immediately it can't be bad and only now
this one was very nice there's quite a
nice little finishing move here I hope
you find the last little idea
so it has to do with just take the
bishop just take the bishop it's
protected twice
I don't know however I want okay so your
point is if I take with the king
you're gonna fork me and okay but I
guess I kind of have to right cuz if
mm-hmm okay so that's interesting so
this also is a good idea you have it
just with the point that you're going
here and then I move somewhere and you
take my queen
okay and so it looks like you you are up
a piece the game also finished on a very
nice note a slightly more tactical move
that does have to do with this point
that was illustrated earlier if we can
play Bishop to c5 and the Queen's not
there so all we need to be able to do is
is put a bishop here so in the game it
continued the Queen takes b7 and then
you can't take this but he took this and
so now we see the point Bishop to c5
checkmate okay so that was a very nice
little game this is the Hollister trap
yeah I don't really know the the entire
thing but supposed to be even if you
fall in for it and then you play with
best play you're not you're probably
just like the normal worse or bad but
it's the way this ended up
you just got checkmated rather quickly
here okay one two fifty but not 42 13
okay lucky number 13 all right so this
is teed delmar from New York 1860 1896
okay what's the fastest way okay then we
got another d4 game and maybe you'll
just pick all the d4 one it's like I was
looking at him like there's like 20
games to start
but okay we got the Dutch there's a lot
of ways to go wrong immediately when you
play the Dutch so should be interesting
we got this interesting line and now the
move h6 and so there are some problems
you can run into based off of the fact
that sometimes this Queen can come out
here a mistake would be to play here
thinking okay after you take my bishop I
can play here checkmate
because after they take it would be
checkmate I mean but only they can take
here you know so yeah so ah in this game
I think we can understand why he went
back well he went to f4
you also could have gone back to h4 and
after this it loses the bishop huh yeah
so what is what's going on here
okay so III was played the point being
you take checkmate okay so this is yeah
black isn't supposed to be able to do
this this is a normal line and I've seen
even there was a master in this club
that fell for this this sort of trap I
don't know if it's exactly this move
order I think Knight c3 must have been
thrown in there somewhere
what is the same sort of thing where it
it worked so you know even even some
pretty strong players have fallen for
this trap so black decides h5 get this
thing like alright so now I've taken
away your option of Queen age five cuz
now that that Square is protected and
okay I'm still hoping I can just get
your Bishop so let's see mm-hmm yeah so
somebody said maybe Queen to d3 and
immediately somebody said what about
Bishop to d3 yeah either one so this is
the one that was played so now again the
point hopefully everybody sees that if
you you take this
the point is checkmate
and so black one here which seems to
land them in a bit of trouble
excellent yeah Queen takes rook takes
checkmate
excellent so an excellent finish and it
is sort of a model example of what
happens when you push all of your pawns
especially your f pawn you can get into
lots and lots of trouble along this
diagonal and so it's always very nice
when you get to sacrifice a queen so
here's the Queen sacrifice forces you to
come off of this diagonal so the bishop
can swoop in and deliver a checkmate 19
all right all right so this is the game
between menko and Jenko it's from 1900
okay so this is our first efore game
welcome margin
efore e5 we're going over miniatures
today this looks like black is going to
win because I saw the next move so we'll
flip the board in this position white
played Knight to e2 the elephant opening
so he played this a few times not the
best but not the worst you can do
alright Bishop to c5 f4 so it seems sort
of strange and again we got another game
where they move their F on early so will
the answer be something bad happens on
this diagonal that will then we'll find
out but in combination with the move f4
I mean the knight just really would
rather be on f3 where you're protecting
some of these dark squares like h4 and
g5 okay so this is a rather unique
position so early on and now another
interesting move and I say interesting
not good Queen to f6 so I suppose the
point is if here which way do you want
to checkmate
okay so white obviously can't take
instead white tried c3 c3
then that's what happened okay so maybe
he's just going to try to play it quick
d4 blunt the bishop the audience isn't
believing it all right Knight to c6
so I'm protecting d4 like a thousand
times so if you play d4 I could probably
take it a thousand times
so instead g3 and Knight h6 Bishop g2
Knight g4 okay so now we're threatening
to come into f2 and the white decided
well you can't castle up so you decided
to go here which obviously undefended
games so I'm sure there's gonna be a
great finish here for one side Yeah
right not if de low-rated kids okay okay
but now here okay very interesting very
interesting and now okay this is a great
finish so here's the position we got
Queen takes rook fantastic Knight f3
checkmate
solicit Lee the two minor pieces whoop
the two minor pieces working together to
deliver that checkmate in this position
so yeah very very funny finish so this
was the big mistake taking here if you
don't take back then you're you're just
still doing bad what you're doing bad
before okay perhaps you could just move
back and and repeat but now you don't
have an H pawn but you didn't get
checkmated so this probably would have
been a better way to continue but okay a
very nice one all right we got our Jin
here argent give me a number between 1
and 50 number 6 okay
number six okay this is a very famous
one this is leg all versus st. breathe
from 1750 so presumably this will be a
local checkmate okay so here we have the
moves
efore e5 Knight f3 d6 and instead of the
normal move d4 there's also this this
other aggressive move Bishop to c4 which
I've sometimes been playing and they
there was a co-worker here he doesn't
work here anymore
but he would always tell me like you
know they calls me I even teach that to
kids that never happens don't you know
don't even try and so then I've just
been playing it this way because I you
know I play a lot of beginners and I've
gotten it two or three times already so
I've got it on the Internet I got it
here in the club like the day he said
nobody would ever fall for it I played
it the very first game like I got this
checkmate so and there's a couple
different ways you can fall for it but
uh it does happen so it does make sense
to to learn about it so after here which
is not really the most accurate move
normally you want to wait for white to
Castle before you decide to put your
bishop here that way I'm never really
thinking about playing h3 and g4 so you
know I better move would just be to
develop on your when your Knights to the
normal squares this is actually like the
main move here so let's see so this
happened in the night goes here so here
you have the trio that you need for this
checkmate to work and now all you need
is for black to play a move that doesn't
protect the d5 square so you can play
here here you know some sort of random
move here in the game this move was
played and now do we see that the the
best move here yeah
95 excellent and so you should probably
be suspicious if you're playing somebody
and they play 95
uh so you should try to see why would
they give away their queen but that
didn't happen in this game but if you
decide instead just to take this knight
then you're only down upon your position
is still bad white White's doing really
well but the big trick is so what
happens if they they go ahead and they
just grab this Queen you see the whole
thing
Bishop f7 and okay I only have one
square and as Arjun said Knight d5 so
this is legal checkmate there are a lot
more modern examples to where things are
a little bit more complicated but this
is the the original game where this this
model checkmate occurred so very good
Arjun yeah yes for number six and you
knew the answer right away
brilliant all right one two fifty twenty
four
all right the very last one on the page
here Shh okay so here we have e for nine
f6e 595 so an alkine ah and we get
perhaps the chase variation so it is
possible to play the move C for this is
a the move nakamura played against me
and assign Mille so that's that is
possible and it's it is kind of tricky
but instead d4 and after d6
you have two options although looking at
this apparently there's a third and it
is white this going to win the two main
options are played to play the four
pawns attack or you can play the
exchange variation and both should be
pretty good for white I mean the
exchange is actually a good way to try
to get an initiative an advantage as
white and you can capture with either
pond and you get different positions
when I was playing the Alekhine because
i used to play this all the time which
is why I played it against Nakamura is
uh I always
love it when they would play the four
pawns attack it is kind of what you're
hoping for when you play the alkyne
you're giving them the center and then
you hope that they go crazy and create a
lot of weaknesses that you can exploit
later but in this game we see a unique
move that I'm not aware of which is
Bishop to d3 but uh it's all going to
work out so it only it's only a few more
moves it looks like it all is all gonna
work out takes takes Knight from 8th to
d7 and now what's the most aggressive
move here ecigs yeah with the point that
if you take how which wasn't played we
have a dubious dis Queen check you can
block yeah Queen takes obviously
obviously the prettier choice so this is
how the game should end ok but that did
not happen
he currently saw that much so the knight
win here yes excellent yeah and in this
position as I was mentioned uh you can
yes bishop g6 excellent and now you're
walking away with the Queen so yeah
whatever
however you you want to take back group
and the game so the game ended in this
position so ok fantastic this is the
game between Rennes Mayfield 1941 so
yeah this is also a sort of a classic
deflection and this happens a lot when
you have a King on you know EA and a
queen on d8 often usually it's like a
bishop or something that might distract
it you can imagine that the bishops on
c4 and that takes on f7 and if the King
takes back you take the Queen that sort
of deflection occurs very often though
this one was pretty because it was sort
of a double deflection you had to use
your pawn to initially get the King out
of the way and then you needed to follow
up with your Bishop to deliver a check
that Unleashed a discovered attack on
the Queen all right very good
what wonder 5050 all right number 50
this is holes hassan versus trash from
1910 and I know hmm so I note Russia's
name but he's not the victor man
interesting I was ready to just flip the
board but uh alright this is this is how
it is again let's see all right got a
little Philidor and then will it be at
the gauls mate
probably not takes uh and he plays the
exchange variation not the only way and
you can actually take with with both
pieces here taking with the Queen but
normally in lines we take with the Queen
you haven't moved your bishop yet so at
the point is you can pin here and just
keep developing as quickly as possible
so taking with the night makes the most
sense
9f 693 96 alright so how is this all
going to end castles castles so far
their plan just fine h3 rookie a rookie
one somebody lost this game quickly the
most boring game what do you mean this
rook moves
now we're attacking f7 you know that
might matter alright and now you're
putting your knight in front of your
pieces alright so yeah let's see it yeah
so now it's interesting what would you
guys pull you in this position
mm-hmm yes this also is a very famous
game of to so I assume if you play here
which has been suggested um I guess I
can play here yes well you have even
better excellent alright good job
Arjun Bishop f7 this is actually a
really famous game so yes we've so
somebody said here I assume I can go
back or I can attack you but yeah but
I'm also trouble if I go back all right
let's are Jinky come teach this class
for me
it's too hard you'd have to be beyond
the basics
alright so excellent so there is there
is better in this position which I think
somebody had already mentioned 96
excellent so just threatening to take
the Queen and if we take here some kind
of made excellent next game
yeah we need Arjun Arjun help me out
Queen d5 and now
Queen f5 excellent a brilliant checkmate
yeah so what made this this possible is
a combination of you boxing in your own
queen and me having active pieces
he was good trash she's great it's all
these openings named after him he's
great yeah I guess yeah you wanted to
bring his night out that was tirage yeah
this is actually quite a famous game so
our number one number one all right this
is Taylor verse amateur from London 1862
you're betting on amateur I don't like
your odds yeah I was Knight f6 and okay
so that normally they take on e5 this
also can lead to some some great
complications so let's go ahead and look
at this this is the Bowden Koretsky
gambit anyone agree with that
all right um okay so in this position
Knight to c5 normally they take and you
get some good compensation and the fact
that you're you're much more developed
but in the game he decided to move his
knight again cuz that's that's how he
rolls I guess and that was an amateur
yep this yeah I don't like your odds
either all right and you're not gonna
like your odds after this movie there
you're not gonna like your ax our our
Jin can you blender here help me blender
excellent good job Natalie can you find
the right good move so you can find the
right bad moves so very good very good
all right who's got who's kept the move
here wait it's great game it's great him
yeah top yeah wouldn't you want to say
Bishop check I assumed he would play
here and then your Knights attacked and
your bishops attacked and I hope you
move your night away and I take your
bishop
yeah so that wasn't played yeah where
you going my god
Knight d5 check no problem no big deal
no big deal
yeah so in this initial position we got
the answer now uh yeah this this move
looks pretty strong
all right so if Knight takes pawn I get
one turn to defend can I do it uh uh
I can't it's been claimed that I can't
not well look at that defense get this
alright fine me whoops - computer thinks
you should put your knight there yes
yeah computer thinks you should be right
there so this actually wasn't played
though like everything looks like it's
probably winning here but uh yeah it
says this is ungood for one of them
look you got two pieces hanging like
that's terrible all right said here with
all right so the idea that we've we've
sort of seen um uh whoa so yeah just
keep going this way just this way just
keep like what you playing one of these
what side were you you were black in
this position oh yeah okay but then here
we have eight for novelty and after this
capture check that one be cool you know
what rook up would be check but it
wouldn't be checkmate who can find the
checkmate in one move you'd have to
follow my rules or Jim yeah I always
play Queen d1 the best example have
always played Queens one so uh
this is this is much prettier much
prettier and that's that's not checkmate
right cuz I can block I can block
yeah yeah Queen d1 much better
ah yeah very very pretty finish to that
game will do to war the two more who's
got a number yes
number two do we do number two all right
I believe that we didn't do it d4 d5 see
46 Queens gambit declined a hard opening
to lose and only six moves very very
solid all right Knight c3 c5 get a
little to rush we know how well Trish
has done so far this lecture so it's not
a good sign
alright Bishop f4 CED alright and now
what is the next move
how do you lose in two moves yeah that's
tough right all right Knight to b5 I
assume I play here then you probably
won't lose on your next move all right
you yeah not bad enough not bad enough
this made more sense let's relive it as
the black pieces let's relive it alright
so we're just we're just crushing it
here is black there you're not going to
be happy with the finish you're not
gonna be happy with the finish this
takes takes
resides everybody satisfied with that so
I suppose the point is if you go here
what's blacks move yeah and you only
have one good app you block this way if
you want to lose more stuff but you'd
have to play here so all right everybody
satisfied with that was great
you loved it that was a Shh amateur that
should have been our first ten verses
Bruning from Berlin 1907 let's do one
more just pick pick a really good one
this time come on which one thirty two
thirty two all right that'll got a
little ten mover here this is Schiffer
versed Channing from Budapest 1898 all
right let's make sure we know who's
going to going to win this one all right
so it's going to be black winning with
checkmate in ten moves all right
efore 'if I've Knight f3 knight c6
little Bishop b2 okay not the not the
most aggressive but legal legal all
right and now white plays for a little
trick so he plays the fork trick so he
took here the point being that if you
take back we for Q um black sense that
need decided play okay I'll take here
first and only now did he take back um
this is probably good for white though
but it's almost over
all right so d4
and then what did black play little
check and I assume you can just go back
with the king but he decided to play
here
yeah Knight to g4 and you ready for it
what um there appear to be alternatives
uh I'm not sure what he's what he's
worried about if he just goes back here
what is he worried about developing is
romantic yeah right right you gotta be
able to develop your route you don't
want to step in front of York just go
out to g3 what could be what could be
safer threatening King takes Knight all
right instead of taking with the bishop
for some reason all right so continue as
black h5h for has been suggested it's
not gonna help them and it's not gonna
help them alright h5h for was on the
order yes yeah I just took your piece uh
yep I'm feeling pretty good here is
white mmm-hmm d6 let's play and
obviously not d4 d5 also um yeah somehow
the King ran out and got checkmated who
who would have thought who would have
thought but now here this is the most
important position of the whole lecture
here which is the prettiest checkmate
very important by sacrificing the Queen
you can play d6 or d5 who thinks d6 is
the prettier move just up two three four
who thinks d5 is prettier it's tempting
to take yeah
here it just fair just repent Simon will
turn it all the way up Oh Oh can't do it
can't do it can't do it
alright well alright those pretty fun
some of those were great games some of
those were so so games but okay in
general these watching these miniatures
are usually very entertaining so I would
encourage you if you wanted to on your
own just go search for miniatures that
you can just watch on your own they do
generally tend to reflect sort of the
basic themes where you can get into
trouble really fast such as in some of
them we saw you move your F pawn too
early you know bad stuff happens to on
that diagonal and it reveals a lot of
things that occur even later on in the
games they're just sort of model
examples of how you can get into the
most trouble as fast as possible
you